qui serait selon vous le candidat idéal
à même de pouvoir faire barrage à la
leader frontiste
écoutez la réponse du premier ministre
là je fais attention parce qu'il doit y
avoir la presse française c'est ce parti
qui doit gagner en 2017
vive la république vive la france parce
qu'il faut le faire savoir
comme la voûte à voir à partir du pur
fait monter ta voix qu'on se rende
compte et toujours avec sincérité
conviction et détermination d'aller au
bout de ce combat auquel je donnerai
tout
vv république dernier débat dans quel
état d'esprit vous l'abordez monsieur je
vais déroger à une des règles que je me
suis dit que c'est jusqu'ici dans mes
relations avec la presse je ne vais pas
répondre à vos questions
et pourquoi vous êtes en train de nous
couper la parole sur des sujets
absolument fondamentaux pour vous
laisser de la liberté
mais justement on n'en veut pas on n'est
pas des commentateurs on n'est pas là
pour s'interpeller les uns entre les
autres puisque visiblement vous n'avez
pas l'intention d'écouter ce que j'avais
rendez vous qui avez dit que je
quitterais plateau messieurs je vous
remercie de votre avis des gens
viendront l'instant merci c'est ce qu'on
appelle faire du buzz à pas cher alors
que la martinique et la guadeloupe
n'était pas clairement en france saleh
et l'az associés vous étiez là qu on a
parlé de l'outre-mer mons pas cette fin
de campagne très bien très bien
je vous remercie pour cette question
encourageant bien sûr c'est le troisième
débat où on va zapper question
fondamentale qui est celle de celle de
l'avenir de l'europe ou pas la traiter
comme ça mais en fait les jeux mais en
restant sur le climat on reverra à
l'avenir de l'europe avec vous sur le
climat vous avez presque tous promis de
rescapés nous parler de renouveau tout à
l'heure vous incarniez normalement ce
renouveau à droite
effectivement emmanuel macron semble
incarner à gauche mais vous vous êtes
vous allez rater cette incarnation
qu'est ce qui vous le dit qu'est ce qui
vous permet de dire ça il serait bon
aussi que chez nous à droite au centre
on sera capable de montrer qu' il ya des
idées nouvelles et les visages nouveaux
on est capable de changer
pourquoi ça fonctionne pas alors avec
vous mais qu'est ce qui vous dit jean
pierre elkabbach
qu'est ce qui vous dit que ça ne va pas
fonctionner rien du tout aucune fiche
aucune note rien il faut dire ce qu'on a
sur le coeur et je suis en désaccord
total avec bruno sur ce sujet il faut
absolument fusionner les départements et
les régions en faire une seule
collectivité ce qu'il veut et ailleurs
une très bonne réforme qui avait été
fait auparavant et supprimé par les
socialistes
avec un bémol qui prouve que tu à paris
avec un bémol
mallory est un peu tard pourquoi un peu
tard dans la vie avec tous fait du
boîtage je fais des distributions de
tracts et puis là je viens voir un petit
peu comment ça se passe et peut-être
demain c'est la dernière ligne
merci de votre patience je puisse
impacter cilic j'espère sur la même
durée mais c'était aussi bien que
nicolas sarkozy ce qui est un vrai défi
mais mauvaise crimes dont je parlais du
temps de parole